let's say you're in Britain on a dual
carriageway and I try and draw this two
lanes and we're both go in this
direction and there's a blue car on the
left and it's going at 70 miles per hour
which is the legal limit on motorways
and dual carriageways in this country
yeah and so they should be trouble is
you could be doing the right thing and
other people on the roads might not
there's a guy overtaking the blue car
it's gonna be the red car so he's the
red car and he's going faster in fact
I'm gonna draw him in at the moment he
overtakes and he's going as I'm sure
it's happened to me
in the blue car I hasten to add I've
been in the blue car and someone comes
barreling past me going at 100 miles an
hour but certainly it could happen
whether it's on a motorway or dual
carriageway now they're not going the
same speed but there is a moment when
they're neck-and-neck and that's the
moment want to freeze time and ask you
about what happens next because at this
moment when they're neck-and-neck they
see in front of them a tree or some
barrier which is unexpected and so they
both need to break and we're going to
assume lots of things like it's always
the case with a mathematical question we
have to model it to keep it simple
enough to answer so the models here
might be the let's assume have same cars
let's assume reaction times are not part
of this we could have those things in
later if we want to complicate the model
let's assume they're both slam on the
brakes at the same time and they break
in the same rate and by the time he gets
there the blue car sort of just stopped
in time so that's the blue car he's got
smaller apparently see he wrote hey he
stopped with millimeters to spare which
is good no crash for the blue guy he
slammed on the brakes just in time well
I'm gonna claim it's obvious that the
red guy is in trouble the red guy is
moving quicker he brakes at the same
time at the same rate I think he's
definitely gonna crash no one seems to
argue about whether the red guy's gonna
crash what's really crucial and here's
the puzzle for you is that it matters
what speed you crash it right if you
crash at one mile now I no one's gonna
really worry you if you crash it a
thousand miles an hour you're in trouble
no he's not gonna crash at thousand
miles now he's gonna crash slower
because he started braking but at what
speed does he hit the tree and that's
the puzzle there's an intuition to get
involved here there's also some math to
check it out and the answer is why
surprised me
we're back so the the red guy has
crashed I just feel like I missed my
chance to draw a crash so this is the
red guy he's he's in pieces all over the
place because your intuition doesn't
work well with speed questions and this
is why I got a bit surprised about this
the first thing to notice is that a lot
of people think the answer is 30 miles
now it's really sensible to think about
the difference in speed which is 30
miles an hour at the start and think if
everything else is the same surely
that's the speed it's got left over
there are lots of reasons why it's not
correct and one of the reasons you'll
probably think is I wouldn't be asking
this question if it was 30 fine
another intuition thing to ask though is
do you think it's slower than 30 or do
you think it's quicker than 30 because
if it's not there's one of the two and
I'm gonna tell you the answer and I'm
gonna justify it because when someone
told me the answer just bawled I'm
surprised I was also a bit shocked and
dare I say it's so good and maybe I
changed my driving habits a little bit
because the red guy hits the tree
assuming all that stuff we assumed at
approximately 71 miles per hour 71 he is
not even reached the speed that the blue
guy started braking at and he's hit the
tree at that speed there's this
difference between not crashing at all
more than blue guy and hitting a brick
wall or a tree in this case at 71 miles
an hour and that was from a difference
of 30 miles an hour to start with and
everything else is the same
it's pretty easy to justify this but the
answer is sobering enough so I think we
should justify it before I leave you
there to go and change your driving
habits and myself on my way home
there are many ways to solve this and
maybe if you've solved it a certain way
try and solve it another way you can use
things called the suvat equations
I've heard people make up nice rhymes to
remember these things have to do with
constant acceleration equations to the
speed distance and time but there's
another way which gets you the answer
more quickly so maybe you're gonna try
this uber thing but if you think about
kinetic energy this is actually is quite
easy so I'm gonna imagine that they do
lots of slightly dodgy things here but
you have to imagine that I'm just
getting a ballpark for this model the
kinetic energy for the blue guy is gonna
be to do with several things there's a
formula for kinetic energy which looks
like this there's a half in there for
reasons I'm not going to go into there's
the mass of the car which we're going to
assume is the same for both cars and
there is its velocity now if we're gonna
actually work out the kinetic energy
we'd work this out in meters per second
because that's the units that kinetic
energy works in I'm just gonna dodge
that so I'm actually gonna say that this
kind of kinetic energy is proportional
to this because I'm just gonna work with
70s but I hope you forgive me this dodge
because I can do the same in the red car
so we can compare them so the blue guy's
got half em whatever the M is and we've
got 70 squared that's this velocity in
miles per hour and we won't worry about
it being a meter per second red guy easy
enough calculation has the kinetic
energy at the start of 1/2 m we're going
to see less the same mass because it's
the same car but this time we've got
hundred squared because that's his
velocity to start with and I'm gonna
claim that in braking you're getting rid
of kinetic energy I don't think that's
controversial and the blue guys got rid
of all of it so there's none left so
what we need to work out is how much
energy that is and if actually I
calculate their number here is 70
squared it's the so I'm gonna say this
is proportional to 70 squared which is
4900 amount of energy it's not in joules
because I'd need to have the unit's
changed but the red guy is proportional
to hundred squared which is 10,000 so
even if the red guy gets rid of all the
energy the blue guy's got rid off which
he would if everything else is the same
I just need to do 10,000 take away 4900
this is 5100 of whatever units we're
using left which is more than the blue
guy started with if you square root this
you get 71 point
something and that's it there are guys
doomed and it gets worse because we
haven't even considered what happen if
they maybe take a tiny bit of time to
react to the tree the if they take the
same time to do it the guy has traveled
less far than the red guy so it's
looking even worse
one other thing to bear in mind is maybe
you brake quicker when you're moving
quicker because there's more friction
but that doesn't counteract the fact
that the red guy is now teamed with the
first time I heard the story I had to go
on the course about speed being aware of
speed on the roads I died
I was a good idea I think it was a good
idea for me to do that and avoid a
massive fine but they were telling me
all this stuff about driving slowly is
important and I just heard this and this
completely sobered me up and they were
telling me alot of other facts which had
no effect so I tried to tell them this
they didn't appreciate that but it is
powerful it made me slow down and the
crucial thing to take away is that is
the square of your speed that affects
all your energy and that's the bit of
our intuition is really bad I'm gonna
patent this one day Bruno stealing Brady
be it if speedometers in a car instead
of going 10 20 30 40 50 foot if they
went up with gaps that were proportional
to the square of those numbers then you
get this lovely intuition that going
from 70 to 100 is like doubling your
energy instead of just going up to 30
miles now car manufacturers haven't
taken this one onboard yet but one day I
hope one of the things this video shows
is that in mathematics sometimes rather
than just plugging numbers into
equations it's good to really understand
what's going on under the hood see what
I did there under the hood wrote that
myself but seriously the quizzes and
puzzles at brilliant org give you these
insights they really help you see how
everything fits together they encourage
critical thinking don't just think what
formula do I use but understand the
concepts that are at play go check out
brilliant dot org slash numberphile and
get 20% off brilliance Premium
Membership the first 71 people to do it
will be eligible for that discount and
brilliant doesn't just cover math they
have all sorts of cool physics astronomy
computer science logic that's 20% off at
brilliant dot org slash number
and our thanks to them for supporting
this video all right let's really speed
things up here I know I'm not supposed
to be encouraging speeding but so can a
racetrack isn't it
this is a controlled environment Oh
crashed